Traductor: Frank Zegarra
Revisor: Silvina Katz
Para la mayoría de los humanos,
los pedos son un alivio bienvenido,
un incidente vergonzoso, o una oportunidad
para una mordaza a base de gas.
Pero para muchas otras criaturas,
los pedos no son motivo de risa.
En lo profundo del reino animal,
los pedos pueden servir para intimidar,
actos de autodefensa, e incluso
armas de asesinato maloliente.
Las partes más olorosas del
reino animal no son letales,
pero pueden arruinar tu viaje a la playa.
Focas y leones marinos son conocidos por
tener pedos muy horribles por su dieta.
Los pescados y mariscos tienen
gran cantidad de azufre.
En la digestión, bacterias intestinales
de los mamíferos descomponen el azufre
y aminoácidos que contienen azufre
para producir disulfuro de hidrógeno,
un gas con olor
parecido a huevos podridos.
Focas y leones marinos no pueden evitar
su flatulencia apestosa,
pero algunos animales despliegan
sus pedos estratégicamente.
Tanto la serpiente nariz de cerdo oriental
como la serpiente coral de Sonora
usan una táctica
llamada chasquidos de cloaca.
Esto implica succionar aire en su cloaca,
un agujero utilizado para orinar,
defecar y reproducirse,
y luego disparar de nuevo
con un fuerte estallido.
Estos estallidos no son más peligrosos
que el hedor de un león marino,
pero son eficaces para ahuyentar
a los posibles depredadores.
Mientras tanto, la flatulencia de larvas
de crisopa es silenciosa y mortal.
Sus pedos contienen una clase de sustancia
química conocida como alomona
que ha evolucionado específicamente
para paralizar a las termitas.
De hecho, esta alomona es tan poderosa,
un solo pedo puede inmovilizar a múltiples
termitas por hasta tres horas,
o incluso matarlos directamente.
De cualquier manera, estos pedos tóxicos
le dan tiempo a las larvas de crisopa
para devorar presas
hasta tres veces su tamaño.
Para algunos otros animales, sin embargo,
retener los pedos puede ser mortal.
El pez cachorrito de Bolson es un pez
de agua dulce que vive al norte de México.
Estos peces se alimentan de algas y otros
pequeños organismos en el sedimento.
Pero durante los días
más calurosos del verano,
esta alga produce mucho gas.
Si un cachorrito no tira este gas,
se vuelve flotante,
haciéndolo presa fácil
para las aves que pasan.
Y no solo deben preocuparse
los depredadores.
La acumulación excesiva de gas puede
reventar sus sistemas digestivos.
Investigadores han encontrado
cientos de cachorrito muertos
que no se tiraron un pedo
para salvar sus vidas.
Por suerte para la humanidad,
los pedos de animales no afectarían al ser
humano, solo nos harían perder el hambre.
Pero en circunstancias adecuadas,
algo de flatulencia animal puede crear
condiciones sorprendentemente peligrosas.
En el otoño de 2015,
una alarma de humo activada
forzó a un avión a hacer
un aterrizaje de emergencia.
Tras una nueva inspección, los oficiales
descubrieron que no había fuego,
solo eructos y pedos de más de 2000 cabras
transportadas en la bodega.
El cambio en la presión del aire había
provocado que pasaran gas en masa.
Por suerte, esta historia de cabras que
se tiran pedos tuvo costos muy bajos.
Pero la flatulencia más peligrosa
del mundo, puede provenir
de un mamífero igualmente
modesto: la humilde vaca.
Hay casi mil millones
de vacas en el mundo,
la mayoría de ellas criadas
específicamente para la leche y la carne.
Como las cabras, las vacas son rumiantes,
lo que significa que sus estómagos
tienen cuatro cámaras,
permitiéndoles masticar, digerir
y regurgitar su comida varias veces.
Este proceso les ayuda a extraer
nutrientes adicionales de sus alimentos,
pero también produce mucho gas.
Esto es muy preocupante porque
uno de los gases que emiten las vacas
es el metano,
un importante gas de efecto invernadero
que contribuye, en gran medida,
al calentamiento global.
Un kilogramo de metano atrapa decenas
de veces más calor en la atmósfera
de un kilogramo de dióxido de carbono.
Y con cada vaca liberando hasta
100 kilogramos de metano cada año,
estos animales se han convertido en
uno de los mayores contribuyentes
hacia el cambio climático.
Mientras que otros animales pueden tener
pedos más ruidosos, más sucios o tóxicos,
la flatulencia de vacas puede ser el gas
más peligroso que jamás haya pasado.